no you're right you're totally normal
speaking of pieces of fruit
this is a good segue speaking of pieces
of fruit
uh this is a k
dorian paradoxa uh aka erp
aka dayton hypernova aka
[Laughter]
remember what you said you could go like
two hours without saying it
i can you choose not to i just don't
always
i'm going to start this over because
because i know aj uh he likes gonna
clip this so hey
you remember dating hypernova
no kidding yes he posted this
my family has such is such hic redneck
tendencies
so this is what do you think is why do
you think his family has
uh hickory dick tendencies um
because they wear regular clothes
based on their gender and go to work no
no it's because his brother needs a
liver transplant
my mom just asked me to pray for my
abuser her skin
had eldest son for they fear his
life now needing a liver transplant
that's right
he needs a liver transplant not sure
not a boy and my mom cried while saying
it to me she absolutely never cries she
shouts at people instead
and believes john wayne was right never
show emotions it makes you look
vulnerable
well your mom's right be a man be a man
hogan
well wheel
um this is the day after my birthday oh
happy birthday
sorry january 14th 2021
how was your birthday oh did you get a
nice dress
did you get a pretty little dress little
pretty little frilly dress you could
twirl around in
for your little birthday yeah a little
baby
we're gonna by the way we're gonna take
over when sherman dies of liver failure
and he will
uh one or the other it's coming forward
we're gonna take over the role of your
abusers
sorry january 14th 2021
i'm still a little bit tired i slept a
lot today
though so he's tired because he's tired
because he's there
because he slept a lot today you're
tired
a little bit tuckered him out dug it out
i went on a rant about this a couple
weeks ago about one of the people i
covered
same thing like no job lays around all
day and did a video or she's like and
i'm really tired lately i'm really tired
my back hurts and i'm like oh you're
tired
you're back hurt from literally doing
nothing like nothing makes me angrier
than people that do
nothing and then they're like man you
know what
oh i'm beat my dogs are barking
and you're like you don't do anything my
uncle was
downstairs with my religious neighbor
and my dad
they're all right-wing people yeah
they're literally talking about the
election stuff it's trump and everything
going on
that's crazy by the way that's the new
n-word it's just like
a bunch of republican conservative types
oh he's secretly recording them here we
go is it a secret if he's doing it all
the time like i think that you know well
it's secret
he think he thinks he is he thinks he's
being slick and everybody's constantly
going
you got your phone there you recording
huh no yeah yeah you are
uh no
can we at least add some music to this
like some dun dun
in the morning when i play when i play
the stuff what i do i
i actually have it uh i actually have a
cued here here you go this is what i
this is what i put this is what i play
for him
listening to like that i don't know it
sounds like they're listening to a
podcast or something downstairs or some
sort of what if it was our show
sometimes listening to some kind of like
alt-right
podcast well i'll i'll say this neo-nazi
ryan
long i know for a fact that at least
one of his family members listens to our
show at least
at least one for a fact i hope it's is
it one of the ones that's
i hope it's not one of the ones whose
liver is failing because all right good
because i don't want to lose uh
our only fan in the house it's another
one
that's hilarious i'm not going to say
who his sister is
[Laughter]
what a dick
[Laughter]
oh no
so they're they talking are you still in
the bathroom
talking about ridiculous stuff
yeah they're ridiculous you're right no
no you're right dayton
they're ridiculous
the people whose home you live in are
ridiculous the people who provide for
you
they're so ridiculous
they're down there they're listening to
some kind of podcast
and then you can actually hear in the
background
you know there's like they say that like
cavemen ate like mushrooms
and that was how they bro isn't that
wild have you ever eaten elk
the soap bald [ __ ] guys mumbling he's
babbling about elk meat
so we have this uh but don't worry that
this is just him listening to them but
there's a part two and i have the part
two
uh here we go
nice scarf [ __ ] i hate the scarf
i think it's cute
anyone who wears a scarf inside deserves
to have that scarf pulled on
like the piano wire in hitman
hitman 3 coming out soon
it sounds like they're listening to
commercial
at dayton ford we're here for you
so here we go
someone says he looks like a kitchen
morrison seeming jim morrison yeah
secretly recording people all the time
he records
and and documents things that i i
i would never even be bothered to know
about
this is now i i i'm into some crazy
christian rightly
his video has four views
all right now we're getting into here we
go here we go here we go you ready
there's a [ __ ] christian hypocrite on
a river there's a podcast or something
downstairs talking about
controlling speech if if you
have a different belief system than
another person i'm trying to imagine
a christian having absolutely no
recollection
of the entire history of the christian
religion christianity
anywhere not just in you know america
all of western civilization oh my god is
he
is he doing the edgelord atheist
[ __ ] i think the one the word is he
gonna go to a bookstore and put the
bible in the fiction section
i think one of the worst things we ever
did culturally was
giving people with an 80 iq this notion
that as long as they don't believe in
god they're smart
yes they're smrt because they don't
believe in that that
they don't what do you believe in some
magic guy in the sky
man but the thing is is that like
attitude trickled down from like
academia and into this like this world
where people have like a 50 iq and
they're just like
yeah like maybe i don't know check like
the
entire history of like the christian
religion and it's like
and i guarantee you if you follow it up
and go like what for example
yes please well so it's like
they oppress people and all the things
they did
yeah but who specifically they like
burned people at the stage yeah but who
but like like name somebody
like people the christian guys like
those christian people these
conservatives and what was your
motivation
because because of god and and because
to oppress
people of color and yeah i just asked if
you had dr pepper or mr pibb
can you tell me which one i wanted my
says the guy who's 35 years old sitting
in the dark and whispering into his
phone
because his parents are oppressing him
well they are
you don't know what it's like
as dude was dealing with the middle east
and israel was so
significant prophetically that the enemy
just said we've got to get this guy out
to slow down
i wonder who it is they're listening to
i don't know and to be honest
to it full disclosure it does sound like
whoever they're listening to is also a
[ __ ]
yeah but you know like and i i
actually wouldn't even mind if if old
earl peter was like
yeah this guy's an idiot do you oh like
if he was actually like legit smart
and like red pilled on things and he was
like oh yeah
no that's why they stopped donald trump
because he was so good for israel
like you know what i mean like i go okay
but he's just going
christianity is responsible for so many
deaths it's
christians have you heard of the
crusades
like instead of just automatically
writing the guy off because he's a
christian point out that he's he is
actually sound like he's being [ __ ]
dispute his facts
it's so hard for me to actually you know
stand there and just stand there totally
still and just recording that so then
don't do it you don't have to do it but
you don't have to do it
no one's making you do it it's not like
you're documenting children
it's like you're documenting child abuse
yeah like his parents were down there
just like
burning his sister's kids with
cigarettes and stuff and he's like
i have to be really quiet and do my best
so i can get this footage and say like
nothing you're doing is necessary you're
recording
who's making you you're recording to
retirees watching television
yes by the way they should hear it i'm
going to get them later they watch
jeopardy and so
my dad watches the early jeopardies
and then he he tapes it for my mom but
then he pretends like he didn't watch it
and then he'll pretend to know all the
answers
i'm going to get proof that's a good
move i don't want to take these sons of
[ __ ] down
oh you never did that did you live when
you where you grew up did jeopardy play
twice
no no from hsn all right we had jeopardy
twice on channel 7 or whatever so
you'd get a seven o'clock jeopardy and
then the nine o'clock jeopardy was
the same jeopardy so that was like the
old gag up in new york where you'd you'd
watch the nine o'clock jeopardy and be
like
yeah louis who was louis the 16th
and you're like wow you're really smart
yeah yeah like bill murray and groundhog
day
exactly uh i i i mean
to really sit through that or whatever
and to sit or stand through what uh like
what all what that crazy [ __ ] is that
they're listening to down there
it's hard for me to record any of this
because it's like
who sits through 60 seconds of that or
just like
even i didn't i i've sat through hours
of years videos
handles the [ __ ] coming out of
people's
[ __ ] sad
sad bigot christian right-wing [ __ ]
who's who you live off who's letting you
live in your house who you use their
money and their credit card who are
feeding you making sure you're okay
um and we're letting you have your who
have let you take over not only your
room
but the entire attic for your 3d camera
film that you're making
which is is why honestly in a sense i
love dayton hypernova because
he is a physical living breathing
embodiment of
the modern american where like
from the 60s on right like all this
woodstock
free love like let's protest everything
all of the leftist [ __ ] and nonsense
that they try to push
none of it none of it would be possible
this country wouldn't even be here
if it weren't for the all the people
they hate the
corny white bred midwestern christian
conservatives
it's like the christian conservatives
for many many years were the ones paying
the bill
and these other lefties and these
[ __ ] you know
uh all the gay rights and the super like
animal rights and vegans all these
little [ __ ]
sub groups get to exist because
the the people going to work and going
to church and being normal they're the
ones
paying the tab so it's like he's a
perfect example of
america in its current form it's a dirty
uh loser with no skills
no life experience no iq no knowledge of
this world
talking [ __ ] about the people paying the
bills
like that that's to me is the greatest
part of this like he really does
represent the modern american which is
the [ __ ]
yeah uh imperialistic christians
white people uh and it's like who do you
think built everything you [ __ ]
and now like he really is just like a
micro version of this
godly you know message to the united
states
why is there this obsession that they
have with
being the center of the universe in the
united states
having the christian faith in america
you know being honored as the one true
religion in america
it's nuts but it's not it's not honored
as the one true religion in america
there's a lot of religions in america
what are you talking about
what's that it's kentucky [ __ ]
hey hey you leave
boyd crowder out of this yeah why don't
you move from the kentucky [ __ ] then
why don't you move to the big apple yeah
there you go why don't you move to one
of the big cities
yeah and it's so funny when you see like
these these
uh products of modernity like like earl
pier
just bitching like they it's it's such a
basic [ __ ] take to be like hillbillies
christian hillbillies living in the
mountains like uh it's so gross and it's
like
meanwhile i've been re-watching
justified and i'm like
you know doesn't look so bad out there
in the hills of kentucky
not a lot of people not a lot of law
enforcement presence
not a lot of [ __ ] just live up in
the hills
smoke a little weed stay to yourself you
know what i mean like
the the thing these people hate is
actually when you look at it
it's not that bad it's actually pretty
cool
is he just listening to them again
uh royce he's doing a little something
called being awesome
okay i can't i'm done i'm done sorry
dayton enough
enough we've given you enough today i
could only handle him at little bits at
a time you know
i just his his
his unearned sense of accomplishment
like his attitude like these losers
who i'm who i'm a parasite
off like i i i wouldn't be alive
fed or have a place to live if not for
these people
but they're a bunch of backwoods [ __ ]
losers and it's like
okay but then strike out on your own
like i wouldn't even hate him as much
if he was making a living for himself
living off and just bashing his family
like you're allowed to do that
if you want to if you want to leave and
and and
you're grossed out by your family and
who they are and you you strike off on
your own and you get your own career and
you build your own life
you kind of have a right to tell your
family to go [ __ ] themselves but
this [ __ ] lives there they pay
him to live there
it's the balls on it and then to have
this
this smug sense of superiority
makes me want to stream can we
deliver out and give it to sherman that
would be amazing